- JaidenAnimations is
an absolute rock star
in YouTube animation world.
We're watching one of the medical videos
that she put up on her channel.
If you want me to watch
more, smash that like button
get a hundred thousand likes,
we'll do more of these.
Let's get to it.
- It's Christmas Eve.
You're getting ready for bed
and everything is prepared
for the perfect Christmas morning.
Everyone has the standard
things on their Christmas list.
Puppies, Nintendo switches.
- I can relate to this so much
except it's not Christmas
in Russian culture.
Everything that happens on
Christmas happened on New Year's.
Instead of a Christmas tree
we had a New Year's tree.
Instead of Santa Claus
we had Grandfather Frost, Ded Moroz
which is basically Santa Claus.
And the gifts that we
got was like markers.
People in America get dogs
and Nintendo switches.
I got a highlighter and I was hyped.
- But you're suddenly awakened
by a strange sensation.
Your body is burning,
flaring up, itching everywhere.
The worst itching you've ever
experienced in your life.
- I think it's either chicken pox,
measles if they're not vaccinated.
I mean like a lot of
viruses can cause rashes.
A lot of times we don't even diagnose
what exactly caused the rash.
We just call it a viral exanthem.
- I've never had hives
until last December.
- Hives are usually a result
of an immune allergic reaction
an overreaction to something.
You know, I actually had
an experience with hives
an unknown, also known as
idiopathic form of hives.
After I came back from
the beach, like I was in
one of the Brooklyn
beaches, I went swimming.
Like the water is so gross.
And then I came out, I was fine.
I put sunblock on, next day,
woke up, my whole lower body
including my butt was covered in hives.
And they kept coming back
and getting worse and worse
like they would just cycle.
So I ended up having to
take steroids, oral steroids
in order to get rid of them.
It was really problematic and
no doctor, including myself
or my doctor, or my doctor,
or my dad could figure out why it is.
I had these hives. That happens sometimes.
- Around the night of the 21st.
I was relaxing and playing
video games on my couch.
Ari was on me because it's snugly and nice
but about an hour or so
in, I started feeling itchy
around my neck and shoulders
where he'd been sitting.
I didn't think much of it
but when I was getting ready for bed
I realized the area that was
itchy was actually kind of red.
- That's actually a reasonable
thought process there.
The thing is with animals,
they sometimes carry specific
bacterias. Parakeets
have a form of chlamydia
that they carry that causes pneumonia.
And you basically have to
really know which animal
that you've been exposed
to in order to rule out
potential bacterial
infections, like there's
a popular one that we
use on medical boards
related to rabbits, and
it's called tularemia.
- 4:00 am, I'm woken up by more itchy.
I itched it and it got double edgy.
- She mentioned earlier
that she has hives.
That can be as a result
of an allergic situation
but you could also have
itchiness presenting
at an early form of cellulitis,
which is a superficial skin
infection, which can be problematic
because it could spread.
You'll start seeing an area of redness
that gets worse and worse.
You could even get streaking
which is like redness spots
or splotches higher up or
in different areas spreading
from that, that can become
quite problematic because then
it could seed either into
your blood, into your joint
into your bone.
That could become really scary because
at that point you might
need IV antibiotics
for an extended course.
- I went to the bathroom
to see what was up
and the area that was irritated
before was even more red.
- And also getting any kind of cellulitis
on your neck is obviously problematic.
Cause it's a very tight
space, small space.
So any swelling in this area
can compromise your airway
and spread to a lot of vital blood vessels
that end up going into the brain.
And the last thing you want
is an infection in your brain.
But the reason you don't want it is
because if you form an
abscess in your brain
which is basically a pocket
of an infection where
your body tries to wall
off the infection into a little bubble
almost like a cyst that
can become problematic
because if it starts spreading
and becoming bigger, inflamed
that can put pressure on some vital
neurological structures there
essentially causing brain
death if it's severe enough
and in the wrong area.
- The next morning, after
a bad night's sleep,
I got out of bed and whoop
it spread to my back.
Yup. This is not good.
Did I do anything about it? Nope.
I was like, well, I sure hope
this cures itself somehow.
- Don't think rashes will
automatically cure themselves.
If you have something going on
that's spreading, that's worsening.
That's a sign that you should
contact a health professional.
In fact, that's what I told Michael Reeves
when we had our little chat
about his bladder exploding
That whole interview is linked down below.
- But after like an hour
of sweating from discomfort
and getting nothing done, I decided, yeah,
I should probably go to urgent care.
- Have you eaten anything new
or that you're allergic to?
- No.
- Have you taken any medication
that's new or you're allergic to?
- No.
- Have you been bitten by any
bugs you might be allergic to?
- These are all great questions.
And we have to ask this,
remember the most important part
of a medical exam is the history.
Knowing what potentially
could have happened
ruling out conditions,
ruling in conditions
and then creating a list
of differential diagnoses.
What's most likely what's
least likely, putting the ones
at the top that are most
deadly so that you can
rule them out and they can't
cause any true harm right now.
- Hm... It looks like dermatitis.
- I promise doctors don't have
a checklist and they're just
like crossing things off
that happens mentally.
And by the way, dermatitis is
kind of like a catch-all term
that basically means
inflammation of the skin.
But you need to know why
you're having dermatitis.
- I ran into my room and
immediately took the medication
and started hoping I
would feel better soon.
All I could do was lay
on my bed and do nothing
because every time I
moved or touched something
it would send shocks of pain
and an irritation down my body.
- I also hope that the
urgent care physician
mentioned to her that if
you have X happen to you
you should come back or you
should go to the emergency room.
Because patients need to feel
empowered to know what to do
in case something got worse.
And here, it sounds
like it's getting worse.
It's getting painful. She can't move.
Those are all signs that
this thing is not improving.
- I told my friend I'm in
so much pain and discomfort.
I can't think straight.
And I've been sitting on the floor
not being able to move for 30 minutes.
What should I do?
- The ER.
- Go to the hospital?
- You think so?
- Yes. Go to the hospital.
- I don't know.
Maybe if I just wait a bit more-
- Go to the hospital.
- Okay.
- That's a good friend.
- I arrived at the hospital.
I was finally taken to a bed
given a shot along with a mystery pill.
And about 40 minutes later, I felt better.
- It sounds like the medication
that she was given was oral steroids.
And maybe the shot was like Toradol
which is an anti-inflammatory medication
and pain reliever as well.
- The hives had been
manageable the whole day
until I was getting ready to go to bed.
And they started flaring up again.
This time worse than ever.
I thought I'd experienced pain before
but the hives were mocking me.
The previous ones were teasers.
This time they were
dishing up the main course.
Everything was put into mega gear
served up on the grill
of Gordon Ramsey himself.
My dad decided to take
me to a local urgent care
because they've got a family
friend who works there.
It was more familiar.
The doctor walked in and was
like, yep, looks like hives.
And stuck me with an EpiPen.
- In this case, I don't
know how the urgent care
doctor decided to use an EpiPen where she
didn't talk about anything
of the airway swelling.
Didn't talk about her blood
pressure being really low.
But if it was the case that
her blood pressure was dropping
the hives were getting
worse, potentially yeah,
that could have been
an anaphylactic attack
just presenting itself weird.
Also another symptom to
look out for in anaphylaxis
that a lot of people
don't know is a feeling
of like abdominal pain
with nausea, vomiting
cause that can sometimes
present itself in that way.
Plus upper airway swelling.
So you have to really be attuned
to listening for those symptoms.
- Anyway, problem solved.
The doctor didn't really
say anything else.
He kind of just gave me the
EpiPen and sent me on my way.
- Actually I'm not happy with
this treatment plan here.
I'll explain why.
If you give someone an EpiPen,
you have to monitor them
for an extended period of
time, at least four hours
or so to make sure that
their vital signs are okay
because you're giving someone
artificial adrenaline.
Their heart can sometimes go
into an arrhythmia as a result.
So you have to monitor these patients.
Also, another important reason is
20% of the first EpiPens
fail after a few moments.
You know you give someone
EpiPen, they feel great,
They leave and then like an
hour later, two hours later
they have a delayed
reaction happening again.
Also, I never prescribe one EpiPen.
I always prescribe two
because what happens?
You keep one at home, but
you need one on the go.
You need to keep one in your pocket
in your purse, in your
backpack, whatever it is because
if you're out and you're
allergic to like peanut dust
and someone gives it to you,
great that you have an EpiPen at home,
that doesn't help you.
- I can have a nice Christmas after all
with my family and live on in peace.
8:00 AM, woke up, hives all over.
This time, I wanted to just
close my eyes again and perish.
- Surprise, surprise.
- I didn't even know it was possible
to experience this level of itchy
combined with unbearable pain.
The itchiness was so extreme
it felt like needles all over.
Every time something just grazed my skin
it felt like, yep, this
is, it's time to die.
- You have a lot of nerves
on your cutaneous level,
meaning on your skin,
because that's how you
interact with the world.
It's the sense of touch.
So anytime those nerves are
inflamed, it's really painful.
And you have basically
hyperesthesia where like
everything you touch, anything that bumps,
you hurt so much more than usual.
- Arrived at urgent care.
Couldn't move, looked like
a boiled diseased shrimp.
First of all, I got another EpiPen. Yay.
And then he prescribed me
like four new medications.
None of which I remember the names of,
but one of them was steroids.
- She didn't get steroids before?
What kind help was she getting?
Ridiculous. And interestingly enough
we also give sometimes
medications that are
H2 blockers that we normally
give for stomach acid.
Those work in like a histamine related way
that also decreases allergic reactions.
- The only thing we could conclude was
it was just caused by
huge buildup of stress.
I'd been really busy and
burnt out from a bunch
of conventions and traveling
up until that point.
So they said, yeah, stress
combined with an immune system
glitch is probably what caused it.
- Essentially what we're saying
though is idiopathic hives
which is what I mentioned
earlier that I had.
Idiopathic means we have no idea.
It almost sounds funny cause
it almost sounds like idiot doctor.
But the reality is that
these things happen
because we're exposed to
so many little chemicals
and nutrients in our everyday lives.
Whether it's in the food that we eat,
the skincare products we
use, stress absolutely
makes it worse and is a factor here,
but it's not the definitive thing.
Because if we were all stressed
we would all just start
breaking out in massive hives.
And if it does happen again,
that's how we can start figuring out
why it's happening to
see what patterns emerge
from those types of situations.
Michael Reeves recently
said his urine went black
and his bladder popped;
check out my interview
with him here to figure out what's what.
As always stay happy and healthy.
(lo-fi outro)